[Musique]
parce qu'en france quand tu prends des
médicaments en te rembourse tu vois moi
depuis que j'ai c'est sage et emmène
tous les soirs mon mec dîner à la
pharmacie
contrairement dre qu'est ce que j'ai
produit alors ça marche aussi
[Musique]
le schéma à tanger où dilma fans c'est
que j'ai trouvé tout à l'heure la cetm
et mon mari m'avait tellement frère que
du coup les premiers mots de mon enfance
étaient frères tâches et des mitigeurs
d'hindi alors c'était comment
aimer bien c'est pas assez et dumont à
l'éval au rythme ce qui a marché tout ça
totalement sur
comment ça c'est quoi celui-ci je viens
de fumer la salle c'est quoi le problème
je comprends pas maintenant je
t'explique en fait si on veut être
honnête on objectivement c'est moi qui
suis un sacré plus de groupe de la
famille tu sais très bien fané qui
s'écrira mer et qui met l'ambiance au
dimanche c'est moi qui met l'ambiance
est à la fête depuis qu'on a un enfant
je trouve que tu as trop près la
confiance tu t'es tout accaparé et
j'aime pas ce délire là et qu'un mal en
ces mallettes je disais pourquoi parce
que le petit riz à mes grimaces c'était
grimaça qui me dégli
casse la tête parce que tu lui dis
quoi sous prétexte que moi je puisse pas
tomber enceinte pour des raisons
scientifiques et bas madame en profite
pour faire des passages d'un faux dit
dans mon dos en a parlé au préalable et
tu vois ça j'aime pas ce truc tu vois
qui t'empêche de parler de la paternité
je comprends pas en vrai tu veux que je
dise quoi sur la patrie et cela dit j'ai
dit quoi oui je juge peut pas l'arrêter
si j'allais être fait du cappuccino
sahara est la façon dont je vais le voir
ce soir le petit je me voir on va parler
les yeux dans les yeux et tu sais pas
gras pas parce que je sais qu'il parlera
j'ai entendu parler récemment envoyé un
message à notre essai moto dire parce
que je le critique est inclus
sylvanès ou me reconnais tiennent juste
par message
c'est moins rêver au bout des mallettes
alors envoie un message que tu as fini
[Applaudissements]
et donc un ont donné jeudi frérot la
fraise c'est sur la tarte aux fraises
tu vois sinon je suis papa depuis peu là
je suis papa
n'est pas papa la folie voilà non mais
dans l écoute non franchement moi la
vérité c'est moi ma femme on a pas de
petits surnoms entre new york et des
multi choix moi j'avoue je l'appelle
frère
je te jure je rappelle tellement frère
que le premier mot que mon fils il a
prononcé ses frères
donc vrai voilà donc je suis papa
[Musique]